prime minister with 10 million people
vaccinated
is it morally right that it continues to
be illegal
for the over 70s 80s and 90s not to see
relatives who have also been vaccinated
and waited there three weeks
you're saying that there's not enough
data but don't you have to balance this
with the fact that for some of these
people
time might be short and you've had
pretty strong evidence already
can't we apply some common sense to
people like that
in particular rather than criminalizing
them
and to chris witte there are some people
in government who say that every adult
might have had or at least been offered
a first dose
by may and a second dose by the end of
august
what do you think of that and in that
case what's the rationale for social
distancing measures in the winter
life not back to normal which some of
your colleagues have suggested might be
the case
well sam i totally understand people's
feelings of
frustration and uh how strongly people
want to be able to see their elderly
relatives
i i just give a very uh simple answer uh
obviously those steps have been taken uh
with care homes to make them as kobe
secure as possible to allow people
uh to be visited under very uh
controlled uh circumstances but we
you've seen the numbers in in care homes
lately although they're not as bad as
they were perhaps in there's a
proportion of the
deaths as they were in the in the first
peak they remain
uh very very sad and we are seeing far
too many deaths of elderly people
and so we've just got to remain very
cautious for the time being but as you
can see
we are we're making huge progress
through those groups and we'll
and we'll go on uh in the in the in the
weeks ahead and
the the time uh to uh get everybody done
uh as you know is can be now measured in
weeks and and months so
uh we will get it done as fast as we
conceivably can
uh answer the question you asked ask me
i mean optimism is a
great thing uh but logistics aren't
about optimism they're simply about what
numbers you can get through
in the right kind of order and i think
the number that may and august strike me
as
at the very optimistic end i think if
you talk to people who are doing this
extraordinarily fast
rollout and if you look at this globally
this is an extraordinarily fast
rollout they would say they will go
absolutely hell for leather as people
are doing an incredible job
but those numbers trying to hit those
dates that is probably beyond what is
possible
given the constraints of supply and all
the other things that we have to deal
with remember
also it's very important we've got to
re-vaccinate
all the people in the first uh tiers
as they go through so at a certain point
and that point
we had this process of delaying the
first uh sort of the second dose
largely to increase the number of people
we could get through very quickly to
begin with provide that initial the
predominant protection the beginning but
we do have to vaccinate all of them
within 12 weeks
and that means that from march we'll be
starting to revaccinate
as well as the first vaccines and that
will uh by
never inevitably slow things down and on
winter
um the reason my colleagues uh have uh
implied
that a highly contagious uh respiratory
virus
which is not going to be eradicated from
the globe or indeed eliminate from the
uk
may surge in winter is because that's
what highly contagious respiratory
viruses
always do i think everybody knows that
so it is no surprise to anybody i think
and should not be
that even if we have a highly successful
vaccine rollout which we clearly are
having
and the vaccines work very well which we
very much hope will have the solid data
on very soon
there will still be residual risk if you
think of flu
which actually is probably less
contagious that's why we managed to get
rid of flu completely this year
uh but with the non the npi measures
uh then covid you still have flu surges
despite lots of people being vaccinated
and
many people haven't had it previously so
you've just got to expect that in the
winter there will be surges of
respiratory virus
and i think to expect that somehow
magically this will not apply to kovid
seems surprising and i don't think that
will come as any surprise to anyone in
the general public